so you may have heard the rumors that
henry cavill is done playing superman
and sadly that seems to be true the DC
EU seems to be trying to do this big
shift and who they are changing the name
of their universe two worlds of DC
coming out with their own streaming
service DC Universe but it seems that it
actually came down to the fact that DC
is going to heavily focus on Supergirl
Supergirl seems to be a pretty big
priority at DC right now and Supergirl
is going to be an origin story
according to reports in this origin
story Supergirl will be a teenager and
if you follow DC lore that would in the
timeline that she exists in makes
Superman or kal-el just a baby
so obviously that makes it kind of
interesting now of course they could
change that the studio can do what they
want they don't have to follow the lore
but there are a few other things as well
Superman was said to have a cameo in
Shazam but apparently that's fallen
through reportedly due to scheduling
conflicts and another big part of it is
confidence according to multiple reports
a lot of the actors at DC are wanting
more money especially Henry Cavill I
mean he just crushed it with Mission
Impossible and he's had many other
successful movies not to mention he
could be the next James Bond but there
just isn't that trust there with Warner
Brothers in DC given how poorly the last
few films of DC did not to mention the
last 10 years haven't really been that
great either so he'd like more money
he's a big star now but there just isn't
that much trust and confidence that
Superman and the Justice League will be
very successful in the future so it
seems like for the time being Superman
is no more however nothing has been a
ashlee confirmed by either side Warner
Brothers or Henry Cavill so there's
still a little bit of hope but let me
know what you all think of this news
also a reminder that the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway continues if you'd like
to enter all you have to do is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]